non
[Musique]
le village bouriatte dutch shell ou
taille se trouve à 100 km de la mongolie
l'initiation chamanique le chanard
commencera demain
[Musique]
jordan a appris il ya onze ans qu'il
était destiné à devenir chamane les
esprits ancestraux ont dit à son père
lors d'un rituel chamanique qu'à l'âge
de 33 ans
ils seraient consacrés chaman
le moment est venu
[Musique]
le rite doit faire de toi un chaman
c'est ça à vrai dire pour l'instant je
n'en sais rien moi même oublié que
jamais on ne peut y échapper
tétreault ce qu'on le veuille ou non il
faut le faire oui il faut le faire on ne
peut pas refuser et inodore
je pense à ma famille à mes enfants
comme extra new york
pourquoi cette dernière se dit que si on
refuse cela leur fermera gauche main que
c'est dans ce cas que faire
[Musique]
s
les textes sont prêts oui mais voilà la
mère et le père spirituel sont ils là il
y a deux assistants et neuf enfants
aujourd'hui nous commençons le chanard
le rite du passage de sentiers planteurs
les enfants qui de vous a déjà assisté à
ce rite lever la main ramaré deux doigts
dans le nez soyez sages
il a été choisi par ses ancêtres cher
lui à 80%
ce n'est pas ce qu'il voulait dans vos
semer les règles sont les règles si les
ancêtres sont descendus pour te choisir
et que tu refuses alors il n'y aura plus
de chemin
[Musique]
hambourg yati chaque clan familial
devait avoir un chaman il avait beaucoup
de fonctions prêtre guérisseur qui dans
le monde des esprits qui savent tout
hambourg yati soviétique dans les années
1930 le clergé a été déclarée éléments
nuisibles
la plupart d'entre eux ont été déportés
et certains ont été fusillés après
l'effondrement de l'urss le chamanisme a
commencé à renaître avec force
aujourd'hui cette région à elle seule
compte environ 200 chaman actifs
pourquoi es tu venu je tombe souvent
malade d'accord attend un peu je vais
boire du thé lui ben oui pourquoi êtes
vous venu ici mon époux bois à à un vrai
alcoolique alcoolique
alors tu aime bien boire c'est ça
comment puis-je faire pour t'aider mon
cher ce que vous pouvez by rinsch enough
élan des chamans les plus célèbres dans
son district à guînes ski il a été
initié en mongolie ou des chamans de
bouriane qui avait émigré pour fuir les
représailles des années 1930 à l'époque
soviétique
je suis sur cette route depuis presque
40 ans entier l'astrologie les mantras
et le chamanisme
[Musique]
je souffre d'ostéoporose fouetter mois
le dow s'il vous plaît un peu plus sur
les genoux une font mal
[Musique]
étiez en moyenne je ne croyais pas
vraiment à tous et chamanisme et l'ama
isme je pensais qu'il ne faisait que se
mettre en spectacle tromper les gens du
gouffre les escroquer et puis j'ai eu
peur j'ai compris comment as-tu commencé
à croire tobaya a fait venir l'esprit
d'un ancêtre
il m'a reconnu comment est il fait il
les fait entrer dans son cas non ils
ancêtres m'a reconnu il a dit tu devrais
devenir rebouteux alors cette
acquisition j'ai eu les bras cassés en
huit endroits parce que je ne suis pas
devenu robes ou 2009 enfant symbolise le
clan du chaman ils viennent des villages
des alentours
la participation au chan art est un
grand honneur pour toute la famille de
l'enfant fait mal ça suffit calme toi
voilà ça va mieux ça c'est un choc
tél
[Musique]
les chaussures sont resserrés pourquoi
tu pleures
non c'est difficile de respirer en
sautant tout le monde est à bout de
souffle calme-toi je rentre à la maison
je suis toi le visage hâlé ça suffit ça
suffit on va te gronder situe au coeur
et tu seras obligé de faire neuf tours
de plus il reviendra bientôt nous avons
un petit problème là-bas il faut arroser
il reviendra bientôt oui un petit
problème
wade chan a aucun problème de chaman un
problème de chaman nous avons un petit
problème vous rappeler comment nous
avons mesuré vos têtes
il ne vous empêcheront de vous
concentrer sur le rythme valentina
kharitonova est une anthropologue de
l'académie des sciences de russie
depuis le début des années 2000 elle
fait ses recherches dans toutes les
régions de russie ou des chamans
pratique en 2003 c'est ici qu'elle a
mené ses premières études
notre objectif était de voir comment se
transforme et comment se modifier
l'activité cérébrale de l'individu lors
d'une séance chamanique
nous supposions que leur cerveau
fonctionne et peut-être différemment de
celui des gens ordinaires
bonjour bonjour je suis content de
revoir ravi de vous
entrez les prenez place voyage était
bien oui oui très bien bien ce chan
avait problématique mais on va y arriver
chanard le rite initiatique de zantan ne
se déroule pas comme attendu
les chamans essaie de déterminer quels
ancêtres n'est pas satisfait du rythme
et comment apaiser cet esprit mécontents
[Musique]
juste avant votre arrivée j'ai été
possédés parlant de mes ancêtres un
grand chaman
c'était un homme dur il été exécuté à
tchita c'était un grand chaman
nous suivons ces instructions du plu
presque 30 ans bailly a récemment appelé
l'esprit de ce chaman qui a été exécuté
en 1936
[Musique]
mais l'esprit était de mauvaise humeur
et personne n'a réussi à obtenir de
réponse
l'esprit d'hier celui qui a été appelé
c'est un homme terrible il est effrayant
j'ai peur de lui il m'a frappé hier il
m'a presque arraché la tête je ne lui
pas plus je ne sais pas comment ça va se
passer demain
vladimir qu'en penses tu nous pouvions
obtenir au moins 70 % de succès
l'initiation de zenden doit lui
permettre de devenir un chaman universel
celui qui peut s'adresser aux esprits du
côté clair comme du côté obscur des
rites claire implique l'emploi d'une
clochette et les obscurs celui d'un
tambourin enfin six ans donne doit faire
sonner la cloche est pendant quatre
heures et ensuite battre du tambourin
pendant quatre heures
[Musique]
il
le chaman doit grimper sur un boulot
c'est l'un des détails les plus
importants
les gens racontent souvent des histoires
sur comment littéralement elle s'envole
qu'est ce que c'est une sorte de
lévitation non qu'elle lévitation ils
disent tous avoir ressenti une
incroyable légèreté comme s'ils
s'envolait âge est allé il s'attendait à
ce qu'il grimpe sur l'arbre mais il ne
semble pas en être capable
alors maintenant il va appeler un esprit
dehors un esprit possède bahir mayer ne
sait plus rien il n'est plus rien la
façon dont il parle
sa posture change
et tout en lui est en train de changer
il verra t-on équipements et le cas sera
en morceaux et il prendra ton âme à
cette fois bahir n'appellera pas en
esprit aussi terrible mais quelqu'un de
plus doux il ya des gens qui veulent
demander quelque chose à l'esprit car ça
la ne veut poser une question sur ses
études
je pense qu'il est inutile de demander
comment les enfants vont réussir à
l'école n'est ce pas bien sûr que non
j'ai dit de ne pas poser de telles
questions aux questions sur l'école
n'ont rien à voir avec cela réfléchissez
avant de poser de telles questions aux
esprits on y va
[Musique]
et
c'est comme s'ils chasser son âme pour
mettre à sa place celle d'un ancêtre et
comme ils le disent et le croit m
même les os du crâne ces cartes pendant
la possession regardez ils ont des
chapeaux spécifique qui selon eux sont
conçues pour empêcher le crâne de trop
se dilater estime que c'est destiné à
maintenir leur cerveau et leurs crânes
dans des conditions normales quand cela
devient vraiment intense
[Musique]
cher esprit de grand mère s'il te plaît
assieds toi
r on ça nous avons une chaise pour vous
c'est votre interprète qui vous parle
j'ai environ 60 ans je suis né l'année
du cochon je m'appelle d'ulm à l'esprit
parle dans une ancienne langue bouriatte
il ya un assistant du chaman aide pour
la traduction
les recommandations de l'esprit sont
notés pour que soit des chiffres et plus
tard chaque mot
ils vont maintenant déchiffrer ce que
douze mains a écrit je ne peux pas
comprendre son écriture
je ne comprends pas aller et cette
langue mais totalement obscures espérons
qu'ils ont prescrit quelque chose au
match aller lorsque l'esprit saint-vaast
et que l'âme de bail reprend son corps
de nombreuses transformations
physiologique se produit cette vague et
qui retrace par mois et il est crucial
pour lui de reprendre le contrôle de
sentiments organisme c'est quelque chose
qui est nécessite une évaluation
scientifique supplémentaires une
vérification
[Musique]
mettez vous ici avec tout l'équipement
simple photo souvenir
[Musique]
lorsque nous sommes arrivés en 2003 j'ai
commencé à demander qui d'autre faisait
cela et chaque personne à qui je
m'adressais répondait aux mets mon dieu
il ya déjà environ 70 en a beaucoup et
chacun avait son chaman de clans à ce
qui est inévitable car dans cette
culture voter paul tous les noms d'un
chaman de clan pasqua le corcas chaque
clan a un ou de plusieurs
les initiations sont nombreuses beaucoup
de gens même des noms bouriatte viennent
ici pour se faire initier
je sais que beaucoup d'initiation au
lieu à oulan-oudé et que le nombre de
chaman augmente à un rythme incroyable
[Musique]
là
tout cela ce sont des initiations
oui des initiations une femme chaman de
berlin sauf est initiée voici notre
futur ethnographe et là c'est un des
nôtres de la ville d'irkoutsk
c'est aussi initiés on pourrait dire que
bailly ray le principal chaman de boer
yati un autre bail revenue dutch shell
ou taille et lui-même ont eu les mêmes
tuteur ils ont tous les deux été initié
en mongolie mais se bat irla a déménagé
à oulan oudé la capitale de la bouriatte
i en 2001 entrepreneurs qui travaillent
dans le commerce de gros m'a proposé un
poste de consultant sécurité snps astier
sécurité de quoi sécurité de tous en ce
cas c'est à dire vérifier comment on
traite la marchandise et qui est calme
ou ne doit pas comme il y avait beaucoup
d'employés vérifier que personne ne vole
collectif tam niveau et s'il ya des
concurrents malveillants des conflits
d'influencé ou d un trille chaman de
cours
non pas un chaman de cours j'ai vraiment
un consultant en matière de sécurité
en 2003 je suis devenu chef de cette
organisation religieuse et je suis resté
en 2003 seules trois chaman travaillait
pour l'organisation religieuse de tonnes
guéri aujourd'hui une centaine de
professionnels sont à la disposition des
visiteurs
ces maisons ont d'abord été construite
pour y recevoir des gens il ya beaucoup
de pièces
les gens viennent ici c'est là que les
chamans et reçoivent et récemment c'est
ici que le premier temple chamanique de
russie a été ouvert les statues
équestres près de l'entrée orné
auparavant le théâtre locale
après la rénovation les statuts ont été
enlevés du théâtre et les chamans les
eaux prisés les eaux réparer pour
décorer leurs bâtiments
[Musique]
ce sont des icônes de chaman ce sont des
divinités représentants des maladies
comme la gale ou la grippe par exemple
[Musique]
par exemple si votre femme se plaint
tout le temps
alors cette divinité décent et apaisera
votre femme
ce n'est pas une amulette
c'est une divinité vous avez des icônes
non voilà ce sont des icônes
l'île d'olkhon sur le lac baïkal est
considéré par les chamanes comme un lieu
sacré
les esprits de lille se rendent une fois
par an au rocher du chabad
[Musique]
moi aussi je suis très content c'est à
ce moment là que les chamans se
réunissent pour une prière
le tight gagnent une cérémonie au cours
de laquelle des sacrifices sont offerts
aux esprits à qui on demande bonne santé
bonheur et prospérité pour tous le ty
guen est célébrée pour la 17e fois en
2003 la première fois ce sont les
scientifiques qui ont été à l'origine de
cette idée
ce talent gagnent avaient été réalisés
dans le cadre de la conférence all
concur sacré de la sibérie pierre-louis
lors du premier taïwan
il y avait que trois show man 3 chaman
et combien le chercheur hauturier
environ 30 chercheurs
c'est comme ça que le premier et à le
guen s'est déroulée après cela les
chercheurs se sont lassés je pense au
bout de cinq ans environ
faisons cesser de venir au tag and des
chamans ont continué
le plus grand aigan celui de l'année
dernière a réuni environ 200 chaman
camarades chaman venez ici les pèlerins
ceux qui sont venus pour un service de
prières par là
tout ce qu'il ya sur les tables est une
offrande aux ancêtres
une fois les rites terminé les chamans
font descendre les onguents ou pour le
dire autrement se laisse posséder par
les esprits les plus forts des chamans
ceux qui portent des couronnes font
descendre les esprits locaux
c'est votre première fois pourquoi la
première fois je veux dire ici je
ressens un tel choc énergétique
c'est juste incroyable
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le moment fort du rite et le moment où
le grand chaman bahir fait descendre
l'esprit principale de l'île
[Musique]
[Rires]
je suis venu à votre taïwan où de
nombreuses personnes se sont rassemblées
bonjour à vous accepter cette offrande
merci j'aimerais vous présenter mon
tuteur
c'est lui qui vous a appelé il s'appelle
bahir fils de jambes balle il est le
chef chaman et ses huit guides de la
cérémonie d'aujourd'hui en esprit je
suis généralement en même schéma il
baignait tout le monde et répond aux
questions
[Musique]
mes amis les chamans viennent d'abord ne
soyez pas pressé calmez vous ne passez
pas devant les chamans ne poussez pas
les autres j'ai une tumeur sur le rein
droit
pouvez-vous m'en débarrasser ça suffit
au culte au requin chagrin ressentiment
mais télé tout de suite deux côtés que
l'aurait l'argent viennent à vous à la
place que vous rêvez vous souhait se
réalise dans la dernière partie du rite
les chamans demande de la chance pour
tous ceux qui se sont rassemblés lors du
grand événement de l'année
sommes-nous entrés dans la grâce et la
bonté vos familles ont elles trouvé ap
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez votre zenden dépêche toi le chat
narcose en donne à passer dans le
village bouriatte de celle où taye est
terminé mais la tâche n'a pas été
accompli ils devront effectuer le rituel
à nouveau dans un an ou deux en
attendant que les ancêtres accepte de
lui donner un certain statut nous devons
le faire attendre
acheter que peut-il faire maintenant
traiter les gens non non tout lui est
interdit
[Musique]
maintenant feu cérémonial va être
allumées pour comme on dit ici
envoyez un mouton des arbres et des
attributs
[Musique]
uniquement après cela le rite sera enfin
terminé
même si on n'a pas livré au monde un
nouveau chamade
[Musique]